When you think about your longer-term goals and how your age relates to those longer-term goals,...
...you have a very different perspective than most.
Right.
I think when we start counting our age, we count up, right?
We start zero when you're born and you count up.
And it has this sort of built-in assumption that it is never going to end.
It just goes on and on and on and you just keep counting up, right?
But there are statistical realities that you are going to die.
And you are going to die at some statistically average age.
If I stay in good shape and I eat well, I'll probably live to around 85,...
...and I can probably be a productive member of society...
...in some way, shape or form until I'm about 75 or 80.
So I don't report my age as 35, I report my age as 45.
I have 45 years left to do something good in this world.
I have 45 years left to achieve what I need to get done in this world.
And so I very much count down,...
...even though it might sound depressing, it's just the reality.
But the inspiration is that it gives me a kick in the ass.